you brought something special with you
today yeah and this is uh this is a real
treat can we can we do this now yeah we
can I figured this was because it's
Comic Con this would be the place to do
this but I have
tell them what this is that this is cool
you should hear what this is this is
fascinating
so this is the well it's the one right
no it's the why no but there are effects
similarly this is this is the real thing
so I was given this ring when we
commenced principal photography of all
of the films I'm a ring bearer so they
gave it to me it's an incredible thing
to have this is absolutely incredible
and it's got the real Elvis writing on
it right yeah and it's got all the the
fine details what is I mean a sword I
think one of the swords from Lord of the
Rings just sold for over a hundred
thousand dollars is that true this is
what I heard yeah a hundred thousand
dollars what do you think this would be
worth I'm serious what do you think what
would the price be first I've never
really thought about the value of these
things and some I just found out about
this sword going front a thousand
dollars which is crazy I mean there are
I think maybe ten of these in existence
right it would have to be comparable
[Applause]
that was Gandhi with psoriasis lady
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]